and finally new rule for this
Valentine's Day people who love
marijuana haften have to do me this
favor stop treating it like you could
never lose it
you know not a week goes by without
someone asking me to get into the pot
business with them don't get left behind
they tell me we can make a fortune
selling Marwan oh or Billy bugs or silly
Billy's wacky tabacky everybody seems
100% certain that he completely weed
legal america on the model of gay
marriage is right around the corner yes
the pot lovers say it's only legal in
four states now but bill the rest are
gonna fall like dominos hair it all the
time they're gonna fall like dominoes
dominoes
hey let's order from Domino's
okay
you hippies need to get your head out of
your grass progress doesn't just
automatically snowball think of other
rights we never thought would be rolled
back look what's happened with abortion
since 1991 81 percent of abortion
clinics have closed in Mississippi it's
easier to get good Thai food in
Mississippi in Texas you have to drive
500 miles and sit through an
informational video where Ted Cruz calls
you a [ __ ] so - with pot in 2013 la had
nearly 700 dispensaries but since then
over 500 have been shut down and
dispensary still can't get banking
services because they're too skeevy the
banks not the dispensary
and we still do not have a major
politician who will simply say legalize
it nationally period pray President
Obama has tried to move the needle a
little he says pot is not very different
from cigarettes and no more dangerous
than alcohol but it's a bad habit and
this is what passes as supportive even
though none of those statements are
really true it's not a bad habit it's a
fantastic habit
unless like anything you overdo it it's
way different than cigarettes mainly not
linked to lung cancer and no more
dangerous than alcohol try way way way
less dangerous somehow this is the year
when everything from socialism to mass
deportation is on the table
and voters love the authentic guys who
speak their minds but when it comes time
for Congress to consider common-sense
pot legislation it's like smoking a
joint with Woody Harrelson they just
won't pass it and I'll tell you why
because pot is not like gay marriage
with gay marriage no one stood to lose
money if the law changed but the war on
drugs keeps billions flowing to DEA
agents and police and prisons and legal
weed would mean Americans had an
alternative to altering their mood by
downing oxycontin and Budweiser or as
Rush Limbaugh calls it lunch
I was reading recently about a guy named
Raymond Schwab from Kansas he's a Gulf
War veteran who wanted to move to
Colorado to treat his chronic pain and
PTSD because while the VA gave him lots
of prescription drugs for him pot is the
only thing that actually works so
Raymond thought moving to Colorado where
pot is legal and he could even grow it
was a great idea Kansas
not so much they got winded the move and
took away his children now I'm not a big
fan of children but I believe if you
like yours you should get to keep them
maybe that's my New York values talking
but this is what happens when pot is
legal in some states sort of legal and
others and completely illegal in places
like Kansas where frankly they could use
some we can't leave this up to the
states because states rights is always
code for taking away rights and since
liberals have never accepted states
rights as an excuse to deny black people
education or voting or outlaw gay
marriage or abortion why do they accept
it with this when only some people have
it and some don't that's not a quality
that's Wi-Fi I can't think of another
example of a drug that's legal in one
state but not in another it's not a
tenable situation because when I leave
Colorado Oregon Washington or Alaska my
back pain doesn't go away or whatever it
is I have
I'm kidding I used medical marijuana
because my third eye has glaucoma and
you know it's it's acting up right now
maybe uh maybe I should
maybe I should treat it it's his private
property and I do have a card so in
conclusion please remember
just remember that legalizing pot is a
long way from a done deal
I know you're tired I am too of making
the same old obvious pot arguments like
how pot is less dangerous than other
legal adult activities but somehow you
can drink alcohol you can smoke
cigarettes you can do that thing we have
cut off your oxygen with a belt and
masturbate which is utterly dangerous
but take it from me it'll get you kicked
out of Macy's menswear like